[Applause]
all right y'all let's close out with
just a little more holiday Joy this is
what I'm
liking a Washington DC Baker recently
got the early Christmas gift he had been
waiting for Kareem also known as Mr bake
was just named as a James Beard award
semi-finalist for outstanding pastry
chef or Baker so amazing he's the first
queer black man to actually earn the
honor and we have him on the line right
now everybody say hello to Mr bake
watching on for
Washington what's up Mr B how you doing
girlfriend well congrat you have the
best smile ever oh my gosh so
congratulations this is a long time
coming right absolutely Kelly listen
here girlfriend I have been baking since
I was eight years old and it has been a
journey and I'm super excited to be
leading the path for open more black men
in baking uh I don't know if you know
Kelly but statistics are in America now
there is about what 10% black men who
bake and about 9% who identify with
queer so I'm super excited to be leading
this charge girlfriend
yeah I love with that smile well you're
doing a special fundraiser for the lgbtq
plus Community for the holiday so tell
everybody about it oh my God yes yes yes
so I am partnering up with one of the
largest organizations here in Washington
DC called us helping us and they
serviced the youth adults and
homelessness HIV AIDS mental health you
name it they have probably got the help
for you we are partnering up to bring a
gingerbread competition where we will
give them pre-made gingerbreads and
supplies and they have to decorate them
in teens so it's about team building and
expression yeah I love working as a team
so wait I hear that you have a
gingerbread house there right oh
girlfriend you already know it I my
gosh
okay okay sir uh I have a few of those
in my house right now and they do not
look like that thank you so much Mr B
congratulations I'm liking right now and
that's not all our season long partner
pilot pin makers of friction the goto
erasable pin of the Kelly Clarkson show
want to celebrate those creating
fearlessly just like you sirar so they
are going to give us helping us ,000 to
help out how's that
sound oh God I love you so much you've
got to come visit us in person thank you
so much for joining us and thank you to
all our guests this hour Barry M Teddy
swims Laura and yall have a great day if
it's not TR
[Music]
Chang
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home